if the Earth had an edge I hope it would
look like this
the edge of a flat Earth
I know I know we've talked about it
before but there's something mesmerizing
about it
a flat Earth solar eclipse
diagonally growing trees
the Great Wall of ice guarded by NASA of
course
the flat earthers sure have a great
imagination but what if they were right
how would the Earth hold up in space
would it revolve around the Sun or would
the Sun rotate around it
and why would you never walk to the
Earth's Edge
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth was flat
in case you missed the news on the Flat
Earth Channel here's a quick recap
for thousands of years the general
public thought that the Earth was flat
and everything revolved around it
then Nikolaus Copernicus came around
with his spanking new Theory
the theory said that the Earth wasn't
flat and definitely not the center of
anything
is observations led him to believe that
our planet is orbiting the Sun
but here we are 500 years later and some
people around the globe are convinced
that the Earth is flat
well how would this even work
do you know why the planets form in a
spherical shape one word gravity
gravity is what's pulling matter
together equally from every side and as
a result matter forms into a sphere
of course this wouldn't be the case for
a flat Earth
anti-round earthers think that there's
no such thing as gravity we only feel
like there is because some mysterious
force is accelerating the pancake-shaped
Earth upwards I don't need to tell you
that you can't increase the speed
Forever at some point you'd be going too
fast
uh does anybody feel like a burnt
pancake no
if you want some real science then yes
there would be gravity on a flat Earth
and it would be weird
the center of gravity on a flat Earth
would be right here in the middle
everything on Earth and around would be
pulled to this point and the further you
got away from the center the stronger
this pull would be
at some point it would begin to pull you
downward so you would have to start
climbing
this would be the reason why you
couldn't walk to the edge of a flat
Earth
gravity would be so strong around there
that it would be impossible for you to
make it
you might never see the gorgeous 45
meter tall wall of ice called Antarctica
Guard railing the Earth's Edge
and you'd never learn what's on the flip
side
but at least you wouldn't fall off of it
there would be other side effects of
this funny gravity
objects closer to the edge of the Earth
would fall sideways instead of down
gravity would also make trees grow
diagonally on most of the pancake like
Earth because they'd be reaching against
the pull of gravity
all the rain snow and hail would fall
toward the Arctic at the center of the
Earth
the precipitation would converge and
start to build up
the oceans would get sucked to the
center of the disk too and form one big
ocean in the middle
a big concern would be the air pressure
on a flat Earth
gravity would draw too much air toward
the Earth's center leaving the areas
around the edge with no air pressure at
all
that would be bad because people living
in a flat Earth Australia wouldn't have
enough oxygen to breathe
and if you lived closer to the Middle
where the Arctic would be you'd be
crushed by the weight of the atmosphere
but not for long
a flat Earth wouldn't have a geomagnetic
field around it this field is generated
by the movements of the Earth's core and
well a flat Earth just wouldn't have one
nothing would be holding our atmosphere
in place and eventually it would spill
into space
we'd be exposed to solar radiation that
would cause cancer and damage our DNA
and we'd have no breathable air anywhere
on the planet
so I hope you're able to find a life
support system lying around
now let's get to those questions we've
all been waiting for
what would orbit what in this
arrangement
would there be a day and night cycle or
time zones
every flat earther knows that the Sun
goes in circles around a pancake-shaped
earth and so does the moon
they're both around 50 kilometers in
diameter and act like huge spotlights
but let's bring good old science to the
equation
if the sun worked as a spotlight you'd
see it from everywhere on Earth
even if it didn't shine directly on you
it would look like those alien abduction
scenes
wonder where they got that idea from
in this system there would be no day and
night cycle
that would be pretty strange how am I
supposed to get my beauty sleep
okay I know how to fix this
yeah that's better
for a flat Earth to have days
alternating with nights the sun would
have to orbit the planet this way
when the sun was up the entire planet of
Earth would experience daylight and when
the sun went down the Earth would fall
into nighttime
there would be no time zones and no
Seasons either but you could still mess
up your schedule by staying up late and
watching what-if videos
you'd be lucky if the sun was so much
smaller than the Earth
sort of
think of this if the sun retained its
gigantic form as it was orbiting a flat
Earth it would burn down the entire
planet that's because of how close it
would get to us
[Applause]
on the other hand if the sun were much
smaller than it really is
we'd freeze to death
that's because the Flat Earth would have
nearly two and a half times the surface
area of our round earth
we'd be getting only one third of a
regular sized sun's energy
that's not enough for life on a flat
Earth to exist
and we haven't even talked about this
yet
the lunar eclipse
Flat Earth disciples believe in some
kind of anti-moon that's responsible for
these on our round earth lunar eclipses
happen when the earth lines up between
the Sun and the Moon
if that was the case for a flat Earth
this is how those eclipses might look
and even that would require some very
special alignment
so if the Flat Earth conspiracy turned
out to be true
that our globe was indeed photoshopped
and GPS devices were rigged for some
financial gain
well that would open up a conversation
to other conspiracy theories
unfortunately many people including the
flat earthers are living in a state of
cognitive dissonance
that's when their thoughts and beliefs
aren't quite consistent and don't always
represent reality
I mean we are constantly exposed to
pseudo-evidence that can support any
Theory at all even if it falls flat with
the bit of logical thinking
if Copernicus had spent 10 hours on
YouTube watching Flat Earth conspiracy
videos
even he might have admitted he was wrong
and have you seen an earth shaped like a
donut
well that's a story
for another what if
I might have overused the word round in
this one
[Music]